oh my God
he's the Tycoon who wouldn't cow Tao to
Beijing Jimmy Lai was one of Hong Kong's
strongest supporters of democracy and
freedom
until the police came for him in force
as China tightened its grip on Hong Kong
he chose not to leave and has paid the
price my father made a very clear
decision that he was going to stand for
the democratic values of Hong Kong and
with the people of Hong Kong
and so he was willing for her stance to
to go to prison and and this is what he
means by by living meaningfully Jimmy
son is in London campaigning to save his
father because he says even though Jimmy
is a British citizen his own government
has done very little to help him the
American government has spoken more
about this than the British company has
which is
a real embarrassment because my father
is a British citizen he's
is the only possible that he holds and
he's currently in prison for standing up
for the democratic values that that the
very foundations of of our country
authorities have raided and shut down
Apple Daily Jimmy lies fiercely
independent newspaper
China's puppet government in Hong Kong
is using New National Security laws to
crush its pro-democracy movement
breaching agreements made with Britain
before its Handover Jimmy Lee's legal
team says the UK can and must act to
help him the UK government can do many
other things in its bilateral relations
with the Hong Kong authorities and with
the Chinese authorities they can
emphasize that at the moment we have a
prisoner of conscience behind bars in
Hong Kong and we have Jimmy Lai a Nelson
Mandela type character behind bars for
speaking truth to power and as long as
he remains Behind Bars the Hong Kong
authorities will not be able to continue
having business as usual they've called
for a meeting with the Prime Minister
but have not heard back yet and their
supporters in Parliament say the
government is too scared of Beijing they
drag their feet and they seem to be
petrified about upsetting the Chinese
government yet the Chinese government
doesn't care a dam they do what they
please without effective International
pressure on Hong Kong Jimmy life faces
charges that could see him sentenced for
long enough never to leave jail Dominic
wagorn Sky News